o lado disso há o que falar andar que
sejam muito bem vindos já é mais um
vídeo e ao estrado de jequié uma coisa
que você já vê há muito tempo que é
jogar o oeste 2 mas há um tempo menor é
que o oeste 2 ainda não saiu mesmo pra
você juntar impedir tanto isto é porque
já entra aí qualquer coisa e eu fui
investigar andava eo pelo youtube
vamos lá ver se a senhora vai ficar com
dó e como estava a dizer eu estava
proibido navegar na internet e eu
encontrei um gameplay sabe que o tempo
aí é plano joguei-me jogo vai pela jogos
irritou a encontrar uma ampla do oeste 2
foi que resultava aí na internet e
parece estar muito bom eo ruim gerei
isso é que tal gosto muito deste jogo
vai ficar agora eu tinha que o filho não
é com ela para tudo só tenho uma coisa
pra dizer assim muito rápida dias 7 e 8
de abril eu vou estar no ebay para mim
vocês forem falem comigo para qualquer
coisa estou lá para tirar fotos e
autógrafos por vocês quiserem aproveitar
um beijo na bunda limpa já que faltaria
321 vai
vamos lá tudo super ansioso por este meu
discurso porque a montanha já começa
assim no jogo anterior foi um acidente
de carro que já é um cilindro com tainha
é parte da perna ao longo da noite
obviamente tem regulagem 11 já na
primeira hora em hora tem óculos também
faltam já a nossa câmera então nós temos
a nossa câmera
vai dar voz da ópera exatamente o papa
câmara este hospital a dor é meu está
muito atento são agora o fundo e em
macaé
desta vez não estamos no hospital nenhum
hospício 71
é uma forma exatamente no 1 do título
deste nível o título do strikeforce moka
é uma coisa sem qualquer logo está em
uma forma leve com uma quinta o está
muito assustado o tabu é realista pois
um só golo já vem treinando com meu
chapéu muito bom está abandonada e vai
bater à porta
ainda por cima a noite e logo numa
barraca que tem 13 janela fechada
como é que eu tenho coragem de lançar
uma mãe deste coloca é exatamente o
esquema da câmera é exatamente igual nós
temos que usar a câmera foi inscrito no
escuro
já sou muito bom ouvir isso a cada
pessoa um homem morto
andrés pega ele vamos lá meu isso isso é
puro alto esta é puro alto oeste
eu estava com medo com a france 2 que
fugir um pouco da origem do álcool às
ruas na estátua igual
daí o uso de outro fundo o que mostrou o
linho pois é né
como não conjugar em vocês não acham que
só vai estra olim deu à luz de deus com
saída da luz manel fixou o rosto do
morto não tem bicho morto aqui tá todo
mundo de pessoas mortas demais morte e
eu continuo a dar enfim é totalmente bom
olha eu uso da força e notebooks porque
já não falo assim olha o melhor pode
fazer agora entrar dentro dessa casa
exatamente lo pelo que meu qual é quem é
o corpo vai por dentro de uma casa cheia
1917 moniz mas deve ter só tem uma vela
do ritual é a maneira que dava ao luxo
assim gosta vai lançar nossa paulo otto
tem uma rede furar exatamente aí vai
parece que o tipo 1
o vi qualquer coisa sou fã há tempos já
que estão cemitério né
parece um cemitério ai vou vir aqui
número certo ponto 1 surround sound
soube que corpos né
a qual que quase nunca gostou e ao fundo
e se se olha olha mas fazem eu acho no
direito
o satanás atanas em que é unicamente
pedro não viu que estava ali estava
içada claro uma porta e está na gente
vai entrar
além de três personagens que é tão
inteligente na e sangue do sim olhar um
ursinho meu visto isto é claramente
coisa do momento em trair não entrar aí
vão entrar olha aí ó só canaviais mortos
no fundo tudo que havia morto sales a ou
em forma de cruz
ai ai
já percebi que eu tenho uma forma dos
títulos do abate que fica no cruz 22 é
mesmo isso eu tá tá muito bom tá muito
bom tá muito bom
anda lá agora segue para o shopping jogo
sai pra lá
tem um cavalinho aí o poço o bolso
achei que não ia samara a ídolos e não
estes têm muita coisa bizarra quito
não entro no poço a cabo no poço
bom pessoal que eu estive agora a
primeira grande played alto oeste 2 o
que vocês acharam 'lista eu achei
bizarro para caraças não levaram muito
tempo novo que o destino final do corpo
mas acho que sou eu com esse tempo
quando existiu sofre para se prever uma
meta seria aqui no canal e não eu não
fui parar tanto esta série eu vou fazer
como vocês gostam que é confortante uma
série com muitos episódios que vou
tentar fazer o menino cortes possíveis
tipo sonar e falar e tal e ri je com
jogo é e pronto eu fico ansiosa espera
deste jogo e como é que vocês acharam e
é isso que eu acho que o favorito fica
bem e até a próxima